yeah the car's moving now  [Applause]  all right they're uh eastbound uh just  past 25th Street  uh underneath the interstate and uh cars  blacked out  here  approaching 22nd Street  yeah it's still blacked out eastbound  number one lane driving normal coming up  to 21st Street  behind him  yeah you're behind them  all right I've got it I can call it  eastbound 62nd uh just passing 18.  Cruisers back off  [Applause]  these high rate  he's still blacked out passing 12th  Street uh I know well Bravo see if we  can get some of these oh and he's gonna  lose it right here he crashed he's  crashing UH 60 second and it's going to  be just shy of 10th Street on the south  side of the road  okay  [Music]  there you go no one's got out of the car  should be three of them let's get FD  rolling pretty bad crash  plenty of copies